[Music]
hey guys mkbhd here back with another
high definition video and youtube tips
episode number three
and as you guys know video quality is
almost completely dependent on two
things your camera and your lighting and
lighting will be covered in a very soon
upcoming youtube tips video so as you
can probably guess in this video we'll
be covering your camera and we'll be
covering a wide range of cameras and
camcorders all the way from your sub
hundred dollar range all the way to the
higher budget of say over a thousand
dollars so let's start at the bottom
with the point-and-shoots and work our
way up so a hundred bucks is about as
low as you can go in terms of a budget
for a camcorder and if you're looking to
shoot hd video the flip uh flip video
and flip ultra camcorders are about as
good as it gets for under three digits
you can pick these up anywhere online
you can even find these in best buy and
they really have very nominal feature
sets they're not tons of features but
they'll definitely get the job done for
those of you looking to just get started
with hardware reviews not necessarily
someone who's been doing this for a
while
from the 100 to two dollar range i have
a very clear winner and that's the sanyo
zacdy cg10 by far my favorite camcorder
in this range and for a couple of
reasons number one it has a massive
three inch flip out lcd which is really
important for monitoring your video and
filming yourself number two is it has
optical zoom five times optical zoom and
that's really good for maintaining
quality while you zoom uh and the next
thing is that it has uh image
stabilization in the lens this is also a
really good point-and-shoot camera it
takes 10 megapixel photos uh it has like
i said optical zoom uh it's just a
really good overall nice quality camera
in the 100 to 200 range you'll be able
to see some footage from that it's
really really great i recommend this
very highly
now once you get above a hundred to two
hundred and three hundred dollars you'll
start to see a wide range of different
types and form factors of cameras uh one
thing you'll see a lot more of is the
point and shoots and there are a lot of
good ones out there that shoot really
good quality video
the point shoot i used with the was the
olympus fe 370 which is a pretty decent
point-and-shoot camera it doesn't shoot
hd video but it's really good for the
price range you also find the nikon
p7000 and the panasonic lumix lx5 in
this price range these are all point and
shoots so they're very portable you'll
be able to carry them in the hand even
something like the zac d qualifies as a
point and shoot so that's really not a
big deal if you're you're looking to
have something that you can put on a
tripod and record with and then put back
in your bag and take around for any
other photos you need to take also in
the two three four five hundred dollar
range are the camcorders and this is
where the um the canon vixia series of
camcorders really shine these are going
to be your camcorders that are dedicated
to full hd video you can shoot to flash
or a hard drive and they're going to
take really really high quality video
and will likely have incredible optical
zoom so you definitely want to look at
this range if you have a budget of say
up to four or five hundred dollars now
when you start to get above five hundred
dollars for your cameras you're going to
see a mixture of camcorders and dslrs
now like i said the vixia series can go
up to eight or nine hundred dollars but
if you're looking something that has
just a little bit of an edge where you
get the interchangeable lenses uh hands
down the dslrs shoot the best quality
video you can get in low light and
highlight indoors outdoors
it's just an awesome thing that you can
shoot video with dslrs i use the canon
t2i which came out last year in february
you can check out the canon t3i which
may be coming out this february so i
wouldn't quite buy that just yet there's
also the nikon d series with the d3100
recently being released and that being
very popular on youtube as well and all
these cameras that i've been mentioning
all fall under one thousand dollars if
you're looking for something a little
bit higher than the canon t2i that's
dedicated for video the canon 60d which
is a more popular version of of the
canon dslr series runs for twelve to
thirteen hundred dollars and has a
tiltable swivel uh lcd screen and has a
more expensive kit lens and things like
that that'll definitely optimize it for
video these also have things like full
manual control and full control over
your video whether it's aperture or iso
range and all sorts of things like that
so these are definitely not for the
beginning youtube user like i said you
can probably stay under 500 bucks for
anything you want to do on youtube and
get away with it pretty easily anything
over 500 could be considered overkill
but i'd rather have overkill than
underkill mind you then there are other
professionals that use things like the
canon 5d mark ii and you probably don't
see their videos on youtube that often
you'll probably find them more on things
like vimeo and other like super high
quality video oriented sites but there
are very very very high end cameras you
can get
for around about 1200 that'll look
phenomenal on youtube
and i'm looking forward to getting my
hands on the 600d or canon t3i when it
comes out in february
so i hope this youtube tips episode has
been pretty helpful for you guys who are
looking forward to investing in a
camcorder to shoot hardware reviews on
youtube uh and i will talk to you guys
in the next video thanks for watching
peace